right the steelers relationship with ben
roethlisberger seemed messed up for a
while and my instincts for once
were correct for once and i'll take it
i'll take it you roll the dice you
develop your opinions you articulate
your opinions and you hope that the
passage of time will prove that you were
at least reasonably in the ballpark of
reality what did i say for the past four
weeks
steelers and ben roethlisberger
supposedly want to continue their
relationship dancing around the issue of
19 million dollars due and payable to
ben roethlisberger in 2021
quiet
peaceful
nothing
they could have gotten this done very
quickly if he was going to make his 19
million well
new deal announced today multiple
reports indicate
the 19 million will not be made by ben
roethlisberger he has taken a 5 million
dollar haircut with nothing in return
now he gets
a lot of his pay this year in the form
of a signing bonus but he would have
anyway it's going to be
13.925 million as a signing bonus 1.0 no
12 excuse me let me get the numbers
right
12.925 million in the form of a signing
bonus 1.075 million in the form of a
salary 14 million dollar
total compensation package for ben
roethlisberger 5 million dollars left on
the table
cap savings of 14
million dollars that is
aimed at spreading that 12.9 million
signing bonus out as far as possible
it feels like this will be his last year
they'd have to rework the contract again
obviously next year to
to satisfy whatever relationship they
would want to continue to
engage in but i think this is it
i think that
ben may be at some level a little bit
miffed that they used against him his
statement from a few weeks ago that i
don't care how much pay i get this year
you know they could have at least did
for ben what they did with peyton
manning in 2015 in denver they took away
four or five million from him but they
put it in the form of an incentive that
he would earn back completely if they
won the super bowl
and he did
so
that's not there for ben they can win
the super bowl and he's still getting 14
million this year not a bad payday if
you can get it but 5 million less than
he was supposed to make we have shireen
williams now via zoom
always capable of coming up with an
alternative patch on the fly if need be
as i try to fill until shireen comes up
on the
on the screen maybe we don't have there
she is all right shireen uh first
reaction when you saw that ben
roethlisberger is making 5 million less
this year than he was supposed to make
not surprised might you know i think
this is the move that had to be made for
both sides if he was going to come back
it gives him one more opportunity to go
try to win a super bowl
and the steelers get a bridge
quarterback for another year they've
eventually got to find his replacement i
don't think his replacements on the
roster i mean dwayne haskins mason
rudolph i guess we'll see i know they
want to see what what dwayne haskins has
but they're going to have to find mike a
franchise quarterback whether it's in
the draft this year whether it's next
year whether it's a free agent next year
whatever they do
let me ask you this if you're ranking
the quarterbacks in the division do you
have been fourth i think maybe third
just based on joe burrow's injury but
you know that to me says something that
he's the third or fourth quarterback
probably in that division right now
yeah obviously lamar jackson's one if
healthy burrows two between mayfield and
ben
right now i don't know but here's what
we have to do we have to project forward
he turned 39 two days ago
how healthy will he be how effective
will he be is he in the process of
breaking down can he stay healthy all
year long
and i still think there's a chance both
parties are going to regret this come
november or december but if the steelers
end up saying why did we do it they can
at least say hey we saved five million
dollars in the process and
that that
is not as much frankly as i thought they
were going to squeeze
out of his 19 million dollars but it's
more in line with what his value would
be no one else would have paid him 19
million if he was available this year
would someone else have offered him 14
million possibly possibly i could see
the bears saying we'll pay you 14
million for one year and we'll roll the
dice if the bears didn't have any better
alternatives so it's a win-win he said
he didn't care he's made a lot of money
and he's coming back for by all
appearances one more year with the
pittsburgh steelers although this is in
my mind far different from the jerome
bettis one more year of 2005 which ended
in a super bowl win for the steelers i
think the steelers a lot farther shireen
from the top of the conference than they
were when jerome bettis came back for
one last ride
isn't it so funny to say that mike too
because we're talking about a team that
started last season off 11-0 right and
we were talking about them possibly
being a super bowl contender and they
won the division and then it was just a
dud at the end of the season and i think
that's what you worry about with ben
is the first half of the season he
looked like a 14 to 20 million dollar
quarterback after that he did not i
think he had five interceptions in
december and and we know how the playoff
game turned out not very well for the
steelers he didn't play very well in
that game so i think that's what you
worry about can he hold up for an entire
season 2019 we know he only played two
games didn't even get through the second
game when he had the elbow entry and
coming back off of that he's played more
games than terry bradshaw did after his
elbow injury but the steelers need more
out of ben roethlisberger if they're
going to have a chance they have so many
free agents mike this year i think they
have 19 unrestricted free agents you
know juju and bud dupree among those i
just don't know what the future is for
this team they're always seemed to be in
contention every single year since 2003
but right now as we sit here today i
don't see this as one of the teams we're
talking about in the afc to go win the
afc
yeah contention for the playoffs they
always are and anything can happen and
we've seen them
pull the proverbial inside straight 2005
when they were left for dead as a six
seed they ended up winning the super
bowl so they're capable of grossly
exceeding reduced expectations the
expectations will be lower this year
last year even when they were 11-0 they
didn't have that many impressive wins i
thought the browns would beat them
during the regular season not in the
postseason i got those two flipped
around but that's when they had an
impressive win and then another time
against the bengals i thought cincinnati
had a chance to beat them and that was
an impressive win but you know they
struggled with the ravens they should
have lost to the ravens in baltimore
they had a lot of games that easily
could have been lost as it caught up
with them they stepped into a hole they
couldn't get out of it they had that
late season win against indy that
reestablished things but it wasn't
nearly enough to get to where they
wanted to go and they were obviously
bumped out in the wild card rounds so i
don't know how much better they're going
to be this year they do need to
find another quarterback sooner than
later though they can't go 20 years like
they did between terry bradshaw and ben
roethlisberger just floating from
mid-level guy to mid-level guy every
once in a while there'd be a flash
cordell stewart was on a roller coaster
where he would
develop confidence confidence and then
something would happen it would bottom
out and then he would slowly build his
confidence back that's that's not
sustainable neil o'donnell was not
sustainable uh especially when in his
last game he found a wide open larry
brown twice in super bowl xxx the only
problem is larry brown was not the larry
brown who played for the steelers in the
70s he was larry brown who played for
the cowboys in the 90s so uh they've got
their work cut out for them and you
almost have to bottom out you have to
have a bad uncharacteristic steelers
season to get yourself into a point
where you can go grab
a great quarterback in the draft shireen
yeah you know you look at what the
ravens did a few years ago with lamar
jackson drafting him late you hope maybe
some one of those guys falls down to you
and and he's a quarterback that can be
your franchise quarterback or maybe you
get lucky with the you know jalen hurts
or or a
dak prescott later in the draft after
the first round
that can come out and be your franchise
quarterback there are other ways to do
it certainly and when we look at the top
quarterbacks none of them were top five
quarterbacks so i think they have to
evaluate those quarterbacks mike hard
and if they like one of those guys and
think he can be their franchise
quarterback i think they either have to
move up a little bit and try to draft
him or wait and see if he falls down to
him but they're getting to the point now
i mean this i i think we all agree this
has probably been roethlisberger's last
season if he can stay healthy enough
even to make it through this entire
season but they've got to find that guy
sooner than later they're running out of
time here
yeah steelers picking at number 24
this year and uh
six quarterbacks that could go in the
first round and you never know who's
going to be left by the time we get down
there and we've seen the steelers in the
past whether it was force antonio holmes
troy palamallo they'll move up
if they want to go get a certain guy and
maybe they fall in love with mac jones
or decide they want trey lance or
whoever it may be
and and this would be better for them
than
waiting until after ben's gone and this
would be the equivalent of taking dan
moreno in 1983 which they didn't do in
part because they had terry bradshaw but
they didn't know they'd only have him
for eight more passes for his career if
they'd had known that bradshaw was done
they undoubtedly would have taken dan
marino they know going into this season
that ben roethlisberger's likely done so
maybe they'll get one of those six
quarterbacks in round one
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports